americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 41
and welcome to hannity americans and
their families and our allies and green
card holders all remain hopelessly
abandoned behind enemy lines and today
after spending most of the week in
hiding joe biden finally issued a public
statement and even answered four
questions but he's proud of his work in
afghanistan
i wonder how their families feel i
wonder how the people caught behind
enemy lines feel now of course the
reporters were all pre-selected as per
usual joe well he called their names
from his little list he put obviously
put together by his staff and at no
point did joe mention the americans that
he abandoned and left behind to suffer
under the taliban that have now brought
back full sharia law and that means yes
the death squads exist women and
children can't go to school girls can't
go to school
women and girls how it is and nor did he
mention his drone strike that killed
humanitarians and uh yeah seven children
and zero terrorists instead joe again
congratulating himself on what was his
debacle of a withdrawal from afghanistan
says he won't make apologies for the way
it all went down
wow pretty arrogant joe take a look
there's no easy way to end that and
we're now still getting people out but
it's it's it's really there's no
no picture book way to say okay the war
is ended let's get everybody out and
we'll go home
no war has ever ended that way other
than there's been a surrender and it's a
totally different circumstance so anyway
there's a lot i'm sure along the line
that there are things i could have done
better but i make no apologies for
my proposals how i'm propo how i'm
proceeding and why i think by the end of
the year we're going to be in a very
different place
there was an easy way no apologies why
didn't you take out when you had full
control of kabul and the taliban was
only beginning their march and and
running over the afghan military that
you brag so much about in july why
didn't you get americans and their
families and green card holders and
afghan allies and our military equipment
out in march why didn't you do it in
april may june july when you had full
control of kabul and could have done all
of that safely and gotten everybody home
you said you wouldn't abandon them and
you did you should apologize for that
joe it's only one small part of his
bizarre rambling defensive speech
where a very irritated uh looking joe
biden attempted to blame to blame
everybody but himself for every crisis
he created he calls them all you know
scolding border patrol and people that
won't listen to his one size
fits all medicine from a guy that never
went to medical school and frankly was a
horrible student on top of all of it
first with covet cases spiking all
around the country 300 percent higher
than last year condemning every american
who has not received a covet 19 vaccine
lecturing them what about people with
rare conditions joe what about people
that just had covered and it's
recommended they not get the vaccine
while their antibody level is high
according to joe biden they're
destroying this country and now more
vaccine mandates are headed your way
thanks to joe dr joe
they are causing a lot of damage
the unvaccinated overcrowd our hospitals
over running emergency rooms and
intensive care units beyond vaccinated
also put our economy recovery at risk
causing unease in the economy around
there and uh
causing our knees around the kitchen
table the refusal has cost all of us
refusal to get vaccinated has cost all
of us
and i'm moving forward to vaccination
requirements wherever i can
and why joe are you controlling all the
monoclonal antibodies and rationing it
considering it's shown such great
success i know you only heard about them
a week and a half ago federal mandates
are not only unconstitutional but
they're also deeply unpopular especially
for whatever reason i don't know like
new york city
african americans in new york city it's
a little over 30 percent that have been
vaccinated but according to joe he's
just following his science unless of
course it interferes with his political
agenda today what is being called a
quote boost for biden's campaign to give
a broad segment of americans access to
boosters the cdc director
single-handedly actually overruled her
own agency the cdc advisory panel to
recommend covet booster shots for a
variety of american workers and
according to even the new york times
it's highly unusual this decision so
what politics first science second joe
it's also highly unusual that the biden
administration is rationing these
therapeutics monoclonal antibody
treatments like regeneron in red states
now governor ron desantis who actually
set up centers all throughout the state
of florida now he's had to go out on his
own and buy them himself joe never
mentioned these until last week but for
joe biden finding someone to blame for
his failures that's more important than
protecting american lives look at the
border for example it doesn't take a
genius to figure out that is an
unmitigated disaster of his making and
has been for seven months yeah a real
crisis that they've been denying
thousands of migrants packed together in
horrific squalid conditions many
infected with coven 19 women and
children are being trafficked physical
sexual assault is occurring on a large
scale virtually none of the migrants
undergo
any proper vetting whatsoever about
radical backgrounds there's no covert 19
testing and people are then being
released into the us and no vaccine
mandate for them either this week asian
might illegal immigrants attacked pilots
and ice officials on multiple transport
flights clearly health and background
checks are very important but according
to joe biden the real crisis well he's
going after border patrol agents and
their horses they are fighting back
fiercely saying this is all live but
here's what joe is saying
given what we saw at the border this
week have you failed in that promise and
this is happening under your watch do
you take responsibility for the chaos
that's unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible what to see as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences there
will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are
joe you caused this disaster you ended
the stay in mexico policy it was working
you stopped border wall construction it
was working you not only brought back
catch and release it's process and
release you're responsible you and
kamala both invited people to come
those people will pay i guess forget
about due process or presumption of
innocence what about the people that
ordered the don't drone strike joe oh
that would be you the one that killed
seven innocent children and humanitarian
workers what about the people who
planned the botched withdrawal from
afghanistan that resulted in 13 dead
american soldiers trapping hundreds of
our fellow americans behind enemy lines
what about the people that you abandoned
in afghanistan that have green cards our
afghan allies all their families what
about the people who caused this border
crisis and told these migrants to surge
the border if i become president think
about it according to joe biden his
twisted logic a border patrol agent on
horseback with a long reign is evil but
leaving thousands of americans and our
allies behind in afghanistan that will
be tortured and many killed by the
taliban that are very professional and
business-like as he quote turns the page
that's a success
make no mistake american enemies are all
watching all our enemies know china
knows russia knows uh the iranian
bullets know kim jong-un knows that joe
biden is a cognitive mess and weak and
frail and incompetent on virtually every
major issue they don't respect and they
don't fear joe biden china for example
oh they've been circling taiwan where
they planned their reunification with
fighter jets what are you going to do
joe because yesterday the people's
republic of china they sent 19 jets and
today they sent 24.
they know you are too weak and spineless
and you won't lift a finger will you joe
you'll abandon taiwan just as you
abandon people in afghanistan your own
citizens now joe biden has harsher
rhetoric for the american people than he
does for the communist party of china
probably china has compromising
materials on hunter for example joe
biden now likes to lecture and scold
americans for not paying your fair share
in taxes which is ironic i'll explain
just say hey step up
step up and pay like everybody else does
look
i really mean this and look my whole
career i come from
you know the corporate state of america
i just think it's about just paying your
fair share for lord's sake
pay your fair share okay joe how about
this joe how about you and hunter why
don't you both start paying your fair
share and your taxes before lecturing
the rest of us and keep in mind hunter
your son that's right the guy that used
crack that's probably compromised by
russia and china and kazakhstan and
ukraine and libya yeah he's under
federal investigation why international
tax evasion and money laundering and
tonight according to the congressional
research service nonpartisan
joe you yourself you might owe up to a
half a million dollars in back taxes hmm
i wonder if the ag in delaware is going
to go after you like they're doing to
donald trump in new york for the exact
same quote allegation
fake news cnn msdnc abc cbs nbc do you
hear that maybe you should be
speculating about jail time and
indictments like you do with everything
donald trump or does joe just get the
presidential protection program like he
had the candidate protection program
because he's a liberal democrat and he's
not donald trump hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else